In your pitch perfect Xcode project
select the main doc storyboard file.
This is your storyboard,
the place where you'll set up
your entire user interface.
Here you will eventually see the entire
interface, all of the interface
elements, and the view controllers
associated with interfaces.
You can see this app only
has one interface and
one view controller,
named ViewController.
A couple of key things to notice,
the first is the light gray arrow
on the left side of this view.
This signifies that this is
the initial view controller for
the storyboard and
in fact for the application.
When the user starts this app,
this is the first view controller and
view that will load.
On the bottom right side you can see the
library selector would different types
of user interface
elements we can drag in.
If you don't see the library make
sure the third icon from the left is
selected, the one that looks
like two concentric circles.
You can hide the debug area as
well as the navigator panel
to give us some more screen
real estate as I’ve done here.
Before we can drag a button then this
view needs to be at 100% zoomed in.
Double click on the header
here to do that.
Let's start by dragging in a button
to this user interface element.
On the bottom right scroll and
select a button or search for
it by typing UI button.
Drag the button to the center of the
screen using the two blue bar guidelines
to center it horizontally and
vertically.
Now we come to the first problem
most beginning iOS developers face.
The background of this button is white.
The UI view behind it is also white.
If you click away,
how can you tell how big the button is?
One trick that I use is to temporarily
change the background of the button so
you can easily see how big it is and
where it is on the view.
This is also a great chance for
you to play around a little bit
with the attributes inspector.
With the button selected,
here on the left,
click on the attributes inspector and
scroll down until you see background.
Select the drop down and pick a color.
I've chosen bright green color for
the background of this button.
The more visible the better.
You're not going for
aesthetics just yet.
Now we can see our
button is pretty small.
And we can easily see what
would happen if you re-size it.
Double click on the button and
change the text to record.
Go ahead and grab the button and
drag it out, so
you can see the entire
word being displayed.
While we're at it, here's another tip.
If you had a hard time selecting the
button, you can use the document outline
view in interface builder part of Xcode
to find the UI button and select it.
That's this view here, on the left.
You can hide and
show the document outline by clicking
on this button here on the bottom left.
The next step is to set up
the layout for the button.
And for that we've got to talk
briefly about auto layout.